you guys kept teasing me about making a
video like this so i had to do it now
let's talk about which one of these mac
studios you should not buy so we bought
three of these and we've been testing
them out over the last two weeks or so
and only one of these are kind of
disappointing
and now apple showed these off on stage
with the m1 ultra chip and the ultra
fusion fabric that is insanely fast is
in saying things like it just is so
insanely quick that literally performs
like one chip and shows up as a single
chip which is incredible but with what
we've been seeing with real world
performance it is kind of lackluster now
one thing that i got to tell you guys
you guys teased me about this and people
talk about youtubers buying a bunch of
stuff and just returning everything well
with the macbooks we actually bought
nine of them i bought eight and out of
the eight that i bought we only returned
one we gave one away and we still have
the rest for testing now one of these
like i said you should not buy we did a
crazy comparison between all three of
these and it's a super super long video
and what i want to do here is give you
an updated buyer's suggestion guide as
well as point out a few key issues and
why they are happening so that you guys
can make an informed decision without
having to watch that super long video
which a lot of you guys didn't watch but
if you're gonna drop a ton of money you
should definitely check out that video
now one of these has 128 gig of ram and
that is the one that is going back today
because it is just absolutely insane
it's overkill we tested out 32 gigs
versus 64 in our macbook pro comparison
and even though i ran parallels with
windows 11 running benchmarks on both
bunch of tabs even exporting video and
photos at the same time the difference
was really
insignificant so definitely do not get
128 gigs of ram now as far as the 48
core versus 64 we expected to see a good
amount of differences and in some
benchmarks we actually did see a
noticeable difference but the scaling
and the performance gain for that extra
thousand dollars
doesn't really scale linearly but what
made it even worse is that for
real-world testing when we were throwing
a ton of graphics intensive load on the
system the scaling was horrendous and in
some tests the craziest ones were
pushing both the cpu and the gpu we
barely saw a difference which made the
extra thousand dollars really hard to
swallow now we talked to some different
people people that are engineers
software coders people actually work for
apple and they're saying that in fact we
do have to wait for software updates
even though the m ultra shows up as one
chip there still has to be a lot of
software updates made to better utilize
not only the 64 core but even the 40a
core with that said if we're looking at
total performance and how well it scales
the m1 max model is actually excellent
it scales just as well as the m1 chip so
if you want bang for the buck that is
definitely the one to go for now
personally the one for us
is the 4 000 model you get 64 gigs of
ram which is enough for almost everybody
and what really is stands out to us are
the quad uh encoders so if you're
limited by the encoding speed for video
we put out six or seven videos a week
this is what's going to give us twice as
fast export speeds and then having the
extra overhead overhead for the gpu
power so this is the one that i would
recommend for most of you guys if you
need more graphics performance you do
video editing and you also do other
things like coding photo editing things
like that because the cpu that's in here
the 20 core also gives us some really
nice improvements in really good scaling
so overall what you learned is that you
should not get the highest end one
unless money really doesn't matter but
the extra thousand eight hundred dollars
that we spent on this one right here is
barely making a difference in real world
testing whereas this four thousand
dollar one yes it is expensive it's a
lot of money but the performance is
incredible and in the past when we
bought an imac pro for 5000 i mean this
thing absolutely destroys it now we've
been thinking about making a video
comparing this m1 ultra to an imac pro
and the highest on 2020 imac we just
don't know if enough people want to see
it so if you guys do let me know down in
the comment section below now another
question you guys are asking about is if
the extra ssd like for example the four
terabyte or the a tier about models will
make a difference in the real world as
far as performance so that we should
have bought the eight thousand dollar
one with eight terabytes now in all of
our testing even going from the m1 mac
mini that's about 2500 going up to just
this higher end one that's twice as fast
it's not really making a difference
because even for things like ak video
editing for example red footage that
only streams at about 300 to 350
megabytes per second
and this ssd goes up to like 5 000 so
having the extra capacity with a little
bit faster speeds won't make a
difference in the real world personally
i think up to 2 terabytes is a nice
sweet spot where you have more capacity
but you're not just really spending a
ton of cash so who is the 64 core model
actually worth it for well for those
that need the absolute most performance
even though
you're not getting a really good deal
and those that will use just the gpu
alone with no cpu or memory bottlenecks
or encoder bottlenecks it can be
beneficial for example if you're doing
noise reduction in davinci resolve that
just hits the gpu and that's another
example of where egbus were excellent
for now here when i tested it out we got
20 fps for the 64 car model and 16
frames per second for the 48 now that
sounds like a pretty good jump it's a 25
increase in performance but that is
actually a 50 increase in cores so we
should be seeing a 50 jump and that just
proves to you that even when
applications are fully optimized and if
they can actually access the extra
performance as best as it can that is
the biggest difference that you will see
so it's about a thousand bucks for 25
more gp performance if you're only
limited by the gpu and with that we
don't know how long it will take to have
the optimizations for the programs that
you are using it could be a couple
months or it could be a year or longer
now with that just like with any tech
for example high-end rtx graphics cards
you know that you have to pay a lot more
money for not that much more performance
it is standard in the industry so you're
always best off getting a medium range
configuration or graphics card chip and
with that if you care about resale value
you always get a better deal for the
mid-range products and especially for
the configurations that come standard
that apple sells for example we have the
two thousand dollar configuration and
the four thousand dollars so those will
have the best resale value if you want
to sell it a couple years from now now
with that we need to talk about the
upcoming m2 series ships we know that
with these we do have some bottlenecks
and people talk about memory bottlenecks
or maybe this uh connector that connects
the two mmx chips and with the m2 chip
not only we're gonna get better
performance and maybe higher frequencies
which are gonna give us a good jump but
also they could remove some of these
bottlenecks as well so personally i'd be
more comfortable buying something that's
more mid-range and then being able to
sell it for not that much of a loss and
then upgrade instead of losing a ton of
money on a high-end one now with that i
want to remind you guys that even the m1
max model is so much faster than
previous intel max but both off based
off the efficiency the encoders and also
just the unified memory it's a huge
improvement so if you're upgrading from
previous macs even mac pros this gives
you a really nice jump for a solid low
price keep that in mind so there you
guys go those are some updates as far as
what we found with these higher end ones
and the suggestions to you guys if you
guys want to see that full 2000 versus 4
000 versus 5 800 video you guys could
check that out right there tons of tests
and tons of detailed info video did a
killer job but overall after about two
two and a half weeks of use we do not
recommend this heist and model you're
spending a lot of money for not much
gain and this is the one to go for thank
you guys for watching click that circle
above if you guys still want to see that
video editing comparison which we're
waiting on final cut check out one of
those videos right over there this has
been max and i'll see you in the next
video
[Music]